pop
[Musique]
alors enfin claudine auger commande
vient dont une jambe ce bond girl
vous voulez parler de la rencontre que
j'ai fait avec terence young cela choisi
m'a demandé de faire des essais pour
opération tonnerre qui m'a choisi
comment ça s'est passé comment un ton
choisi et bien se passer simplement
terence young entendu parler moi et m'a
demandé de lui envoyer des photos ce que
j'ai fait ensuite il m'a téléphoné et
m'a demandé de faire des essais alors
pour le rôle principal domino opération
tonnerre
je fais les essais et voilà l
chaudronnerie
que peut-on dire qu'en pensez vous
seul camry pas chaîne sport cherche un
acteur bien chaude il a ce côté comme ça
lorsqu'on rencontre un peu renfermé un
peu dure un peu froid puis lorsqu'on
commence à me connaître on découvre un
être sensible
aimable facile à vivre plein de
générosité mais il est aussi charmeur
que à la ville qu'à l'écran
peut-être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus je
crois mais c'est pas dangereux dans ce
cas dangereux pour qui au nom
claude viollet vous avez joué au termina
sionnel populaire et maintenant vous
avez joué du gan féminine et du molière
donc est-ce que vous avez l'impression
de faire le même métier
absolument c'est vrai du jouet manière
avec dirigé par jean vilar au tnp et de
jouer ian fleming il ya une différence
entre un jeu c'est à dire que de tourner
avec un james bond ont tourné une chose
d'injuste à fleur de peau c'est
formidable on frissonne comme ça puis de
jouer au tnb
c'est profond c'est c'est une joie de
comédienne absolument différente mais
c'est deux choses que j'aime
on dit que le déloger que vous mettez en
colère lorsque l'on parle du titre de
miss france que vous avez fait vrai non
je vais pas un tollé mais j'ai
l'impression que quand j'aurai 70 ans
que je ne suis pas une vieille dame du
cros maire on me dira vraiment mais
c'est la galette des rois
on est la reine de la soirée bon c'est
amusant et mandarines d'honneur et puis
voilà vous elle poursuit toute ma vie
revenons à opération tonnerre est ce que
vous pouvez nous parler de ses prouesses
physiques nombreuses de ce film étonnant
si je voudrais beaucoup d'exploits enfin
domino louis cette jeune femme que
j'adapte oui la première fois qu'une
rencontre bond et nagent à peu près par
10 mètres de fond elle la chevauchée une
tortue de mer immense succès immense
tortues de mer comme ça et bandes qui la
cherchent la trouve là l'a suivi et la
trouve et à maman mon pied se trouve
coincé dans un dans un rock dans un
morceau de cora comme ça et je ne peux
plus bouger je n'ai pas de doute elle
n'est qu'un masque c'est la mort est bon
mais heureux
[Rires]
oh
e
[Musique]